what up nothing it's been a crazy few
days I got my car broken into last night
no front was there something in it or
you just just go breakin I have a garage
I didn't park in my garage and the back
window was broken into and someone stole
my little $200 like battery that jump
jump starts the car but it was like
$1000 or no it was $400 to fix it just
sucks yeah I'm also pretty sure I've
Corona oh no you're feeling it yeah Adam
like Adam Ryan my coworker he confirmed
has it he lives in Austin though but I'm
pretty sure I have it were you in
contact with him or you just think you
have it in general I just think I have
it no I was going to the office up until
Thursday but I thought that was okay
because I was the only one in the office
right and I didn't and I was like I I
didn't like see ya and Alan was only
there one of the days and I didn't see
or talk to anyone even like I would I
drove in I parked on the street and I
just walked right up but I feel like
[__] but not that bad not bad enough
that I can't do stuff but I you know
that's a bummer what's going on with you
well on the bright side for you you got
to talk to your hero yeah so the other
day for the listeners made Sean are
extra UFC nerds one of my favorite guys
is he your favorite you like I like him
but he's not my favorite guy I feel you
I feel connected to him yeah so
basically his name's Ben Askren he's
interesting because he's very polarizing
I would say he has more people who hate
him than loves him but the people who
love him love him the people who hate
him hate him so on last week I gave a
lecture on cold emailing and literally
the day before I just cold tweeted at
him and then we became friends in the
inbox and then we just did like a
conference call and we've been chatting
and that was awesome and what was your
cold tweet at him he tweeted out a
podcast that he liked and I tweeted oh
hey I was actually on that same podcast
like
two months ago and uh and then i DM to
him the episode I go hey I was just on
that I see you're doing XY and Z I do
this this and this I just like you but
like if you ever want to like shoot the
[__] let me know that's amazing and then
you you had a call with him he's a cool
guy you guys are gonna hang out or be
best friends or what I pray I trying to
convince Ben out okay so Ben Askren is
he's kind of like this he's kind of like
I think the people who like them are
like the Jordan Peterson crowd like the
people who never had good fathers and
want to learn how to be men you know I
mean yeah like discipline even though
he's kind of a loudmouth and I'm like
dude bed you have to like you could cut
like you can like copy all like you
could like the same way Dave Asbury has
built this huge thing you could do that
too by selling workout stuff and I'm
trying to give it him to do that yeah he
has a very big brand and he's a very he
has a very unique personality so you I
could see that working for him yeah and
I'm trying to convince him to do that
he's based in Wisconsin so I don't know
like if he has like a whole bunch of
like internet nerds hanging out with him
that he truly understands what he's
capable of and I'm trying to be his
nerdy friend that's good and fighters
don't have a very long shelf life like
he's retired now so you know they have
to figure out this I got a second act
well he told me he has a wrestling
academy and that they're not in session
right now so he's like I got I got a lot
of free time and so I asked him if you
wanted to come on here and he said yeah
so if you want him to come on the next
couple of days or weeks we totally can
do it yeah we should do a brainstorm
with Ben on what Ben can do like what
would I do if I was Ben
I think it'd be cool to brainstorm those
ideas I'm gonna write that down I'll
email them right after this cool
and we'll research a bunch of things
that other either athletes or
celebrities have done to leverage their
name their brand kind of like what we
were talking about with Lance Armstrong
yeah the same conversation we had with
Lance we should do a full lap with Ben
on that I'll set that up you want to
talk about some new stuff that's going
around
sure okay so first thing teachable you
see teachable sould I did see that
okay so teachable is you to me I hate
comparing things because I want to be
disrespectful to teachable but
teachables like you to me it's like you
to me with one core differ
so you to me is like you go to you to me
to find what you want to learn teachable
is hey I can make you know you can make
your website cold emailing calm and you
can sell your course on your brand on
your site and they make it easy you
don't have to know how to code to
basically spin up an online class on
your own website yeah and you and I are
friends yeah I think you are too right I
don't know the guy but I'm really
familiar with a thing and people know my
education nerd so I'm like kind of was
very fascinated about their business and
they did a pretty phenomenal job they
were at like 20 million or so in revenue
I think they sold for closer to 200 250
millions of them I talked to encore
that's how you founded it and he said
that it was very lucrative and it was a
it was a good it worked out quite well
you know I'm super cool I'm proud of
that and their last round was at 250
million so I don't know if it's sold at
the same price it was just recently so I
don't know if it's sold at that price or
above that even that'd be kind of
amazing I don't know all I know is that
it's how it was a good deal for him
and he is he's a he's an immigrant from
India came here at age 18 so love love
the story and I believe they have
several teachers who use teachable and
make over like a million dollars a year
something like that I think they have
some some real success stories maybe it
actually told me it might not be a
million I don't exactly know first no
there there there are seven-figure
annual earners yeah they're mostly like
affiliate marketer types but whatever
let's not let's not worry it's like we
do you say teachers people think like an
English teacher and it's actually like
you know well he told me he told me the
big one of the top earners was a guy who
has an excel class
yeah I've seen that and you could
actually Google I've done this many
times you can Google you know hype most
profiting or sort of moat highest
revenue teachable classes and you can
find the list I think they even have it
on their website the most popular
classes there's like a social media
marketing there's Excel
how to do Excel class there's a coding
one there's a bunch of those did you do
a podcast by your I don't listen to any
of our podcast by the way because you
don't ever listen to your own stuff did
you don't even listen to my voice mail
yeah it's hilarious let alone you
talking for a long time did you launch
your
individual episode so I have two
episodes I did one on Thursday
I didn't launch it I thought it sucked
and then the editor I think has
coronavirus as well so he's been like in
and out of the hospital and he has like
an underlying lung condition so he's
like trying to make sure he died did
another you know kick it in a bad spot
so he didn't publish it and I was like
you know I got cold feet I got to either
ship it right away or I'll overthink it
that's how I think you should do it and
so so he listened to me he's like what
you talked about this is good and so
we're gonna ship that I have to banked
and then I also at the end of the last
one I had this idea during the podcast
to do a like morning routine thing so
like you're in your house right now
right here in your kitchen and we're all
at home and everyone's getting a little
crazy and trying to figure out like oh
I'm gonna work out by like opening and
closing the fridge 50 times like people
are trying to find a way to feel good
and not go insane and I've had this
morning routine I've done for years now
that's a nine minute morning routine and
so on the podcast I was like I should
just make a podcast that's just that
this is just the nine minute morning
routine you can was do it's just free
just put it out there so I recorded that
last night so I had two episodes in the
bank plus the morning routine like thing
recorded and so hopefully all those will
come out this week are you working out
yeah I'm working out yeah so we have
we've had a home gym or like a room that
we turned into a gym and now I'm using
the [__] out of it I have a home gym in
my garage like a nice one like I've got
like it's like 40 pounds for squat like
a squat rack heavy bag I have all types
of [__] and I talked to a guy the other
day who was a listener or something like
that he messaged me on Twitter and he
said that their home fitness equipment
is selling like crazy he's like we can
keep up hotcakes
I ordered a thousand pounds worth of
weights on Amazon last year with free
shipping
yeah the delivery on weights is insane I
felt so guilty because the guy bringing
it up to my house like up the 15 steps
is like you know breaking his back for
this thing I'm never gonna use and so I
bought those Bowflex dumbbells which is
like it's one dumb but I have power
blocks you rotate it and it like can be
any weight you want those are actually
pretty handy yeah I know I have those
those are my favorite do you want to
talk about air being so nice
week we could do the trend stuff we want
to talk about trend stuff but I and I it
was a good one but I think we have a lot
here do you want to talk about Airbnb
now we have a lot so we're gonna do two
things we're gonna talk a little bit
about Airbnb and then we're gonna start
this thing that we we we teased last
week which is Y Combinator had their
demo day and it's like a goldmine of new
ideas and it's sort of you know YC is
Harvard and so we're gonna take a look
at this batch of companies and we're
gonna break them down we're gonna do
like five or six of them today and if
it's fun we might do the rest I mean the
list is like a hundred plus I don't know
how long we can do this but let's do
like five today and let's see what
happens so we'll do both those things in
this episode did you want to do let's
talk Airbnb first thing yeah do it
so Airbnb some interesting things are
going on so Airbnb you know very well is
awesome company one of the sort of most
successful startups of the last decade
or so and was about to go public this
year and I was preparing for it and now
with coronavirus you know travel has
stopped hospitality
you know hotels casinos they're all
taking a total beating and Airbnb of
course is gonna get caught up in the
crossfire as well and so a couple
interesting things here so Airbnb
financially you know their revenue must
have dropped by fifty sixty seventy
eighty percent essentially overnight and
with an indefinite time span we don't
know how long that's gonna last the
second thing is Airbnb not only does
have a huge you know staff on payroll
and now revenue drops but all the hosts
were essentially small small small
entrepreneurs so some people did you
know a traditional thing they just
rented out an extra bedroom in their
house but a lot of people once they got
a taste of that money they started
buying places renting out places and
subleasing and basically putting it on
air and bebe and so all those people now
there's this thing that was a moneymaker
for a couple years has gone to zero and
so I think there's something very
interesting that's gonna happen where
what happens to all these hosts who got
places just to Airbnb them and now the
Airbnb income has sort of totally dried
up are they gonna default on their
mortgages are they gonna default on the
rent payments if they're if they're
subleasing or are they gonna turn into
just normal rentals I don't know what's
gonna happen
about all this so you already know
what's going on in Zillow you're the one
who told me right well I did see some
charts yes so I saw some charts that
basically showed on Zillow normal
housing so just normal rentals not a
short-term Airbnb stay but just here's
an apartment for lease for six months is
exploding so like it looks like the
coronavirus it's like here's last month
one little blue dot this month fifteen
blue dots on the map right it's like the
number of listings is exploding for
rentals which is also bad for Airbnb
because in places like San Francisco
where there's a housing shortage and for
years Airbnb has been saying oh we don't
contribute to the housing shortage we
are we're a different thing altogether
well now it's actually kind of a whether
it's whether it's truly the the proof or
not I don't know but it certainly does
look like if you're somebody who was
anti urban B you have a lot of evidence
a lot of ammunition now to say hey look
when we turned Airbnb off look at how
much more housing supply came on the
market look how that lowers rents for
everybody well you know what Airbnb is
doing now though is long-term rentals
they've been getting into that for a
while where you could rent something for
many months maybe many years and that
part is growing so there's growing a lot
right now right so I'm curious whether
people in cities who are anti Airbnb are
gonna take this and run with it and yes
the answer is yes very sensitive to
legislation right they changed some
rules here in San Francisco where it's
like you can only do 90 days out of the
year and you have to live in the place
you have to prove that blah blah and
that you know it eliminated like 30 or
40 percent of the listings overnight
when that legislation happened to your
or two ago so now I wonder if it's gonna
get worse saundra you know Sondra I'm
googling right now you know them no oh
that's the like it's a hotel or explain
saunder it's basically if you are
traveling for work and you want to go
stay somewhere you'll stay at a saunder
often let's see I'll go to sander comm
it's also if you want to stay somewhere
for like three months like let's say
you're going somewhere for three months
and you want to and you have to make a
lot of money in order to do this it's
high-end [__] like in San Francisco it's
like five or six grand a month I need a
place to stay or work we know it's time
the better yeah the best parts of home
and hotel so it's like it's like an
apartment that you can rent for two
months right so the PERT housing but
done well yes but they just laid off 20%
of their company it looks like oh wow
yeah today so I think this is gonna be
very interesting how these different
companies get affected you know I'm
rooting for Airbnb I think it's a great
product I think it's a great company I
hope that they have you know a war chest
of cash that lets them endure this time
but you know we'll see
it's a keeping an eye on them if you
could invest a little bit what you can
you can go and buy secondary shares if
you're gonna invest money at Airbnb x'
previous valuation I think they raised
money on a thirty billion dollar
valuation would you invest in that right
now what I need to know more right I
need to know about the how the company's
financials look let's say that revenue
drops people let's say revenue drops
seventy percent for them I'm not so
concerned about the 70 percent drop
because that's that I think is is more
temporary so I just need to know do they
have enough cash in the bank to endure
this or that that's three billion
dollars okay so three billion dollars
you know they're probably burning
several million a month but like okay
three billion should still last you
through this time and then the other
question is where the fundamentals good
to begin with so a lot of times these
companies don't have great unit
economics or fundamentals to begin with
and so when the downturn comes and
people start looking for things that are
more stable more sure bets these
high-growth but poor unit economic
companies they struggle they weren't
profitable in 2018 this is like a
analysts call again I think they're also
profitable in 2019 this is all public
information right so yeah so if they're
publicly if they're profitable right now
even with this explosive growth and yeah
it's probably a pretty good bet to pick
up a little secondary there okay I guess
we'll see what happens
you want to talk about some Y Combinator
stuff yeah so so we're gonna go through
a couple of the companies in the batch
you know they're these are what we won't
say anything that's to what I'll call to
private information so we'll do what's
mostly public information about these
companies so we'll start with the first
one wait I'll draw it before we get into
that you
can you can I tell you something that
was striking about this list how many
lists were there 150 yeah shockingly
Africa African and Indian based yes this
has been a trend in the last year or two
for Y Combinator they did two things
they went and did a road show some
Michael Seibel who was the CEO of YC for
a while actually you might still be so
he went on a road show through Africa
through India and met a lot been a bunch
of entrepreneurs had they had a bunch of
events and they sort of opened up the
doors to those applicants and really got
people excited about coming to YC and
their bet was that hey look a lot of the
growth opportunity and the best
companies are you know we can go fish in
this pond where not everybody else is
fishing and you know certainly 500
startups has did this many many years
ago where they just the investment
companies all around the world this has
not been the sort of way that most
Silicon Valley investors have been
operating they're not actively going and
hunting for great companies in India or
Brazil or in Africa but yeah it's pretty
amazing about how like there's I see a
lot of Latin America a ton of India and
a ton of Africa and what's funny is a
lot of them are just you know flex port
for Brazil it's like this other
successful YC company or it's like same
one says once tagline is smile direct
Club for Latin America right yeah but
that's literally it
yeah flex port for India
sorry flex port for Africa yeah it's
pretty crazy and I think that's a great
move yeah for sure because a lot of
these companies that that work when
they're not purely software based
they're gonna scale slowly they're not
gonna expand everywhere overnight so
same thing happen to Airbnb Airbnb got
cloned in Europe and in all different
parts of the world sometimes they they
were able to catch up and beat them most
of the time they weren't and they had to
buy a piece of them or acquire them or
they just lost and they said okay I
guess we're not gonna be the number one
player in the UK we're gonna be two or
three or and it where else yeah
and so why don't you want it this
morning you want to start it off yeah so
let's do cron so cron is an app that
websites just crontab CRO and
app and what these guys are trying to do
is essentially superhuman for your
calendar so that assumes you know what
superhuman is which is this really slick
and very hyped email client I used it
for a while I stopped I don't know about
you do you have you sue Freeman I'm
still using it verdicts still out if I
love it but their tagline for people who
don't know superhuman is the calendar
for professionals right so there are
thesis is look at the market for
calendar users for just if you just take
google calendar is 500 million people
and what they're trying to do is take
the top you know set of prosumers right
so professionals people who really care
about efficiency people who are heavy
power users of the calendar app and
they're trying to say can we get the top
X percent they said top 20% but really
is gonna end up being the top 2% of
people to pay $19 a month to have you
know their Google calendar on steroids
what side of what's 1% of 500 million 15
million wait no that's 5 million yeah
that's 5 million ok so five million
people paying 19 bucks a month not bad
so so they're trying to go after that
they basically made a very slick looking
calendar so it's got a you know
aesthetically it looks looks better they
have hot keys and little short commands
and oh you want to set up a meeting and
it's hard to sort of say oh I'm free
Tuesday from 1 to 2 and Thursday from 3
to 4 it's like you just share your
availability and make it make it really
easy so they have a bunch of these
features and they have a thousand users
on the wait list who are sort of ready
to pay and there they've on-boarded the
first 50 paying customers so far so
they're they're doing that thing that YC
companies do you'll see this a lot is
big idea and then good traction but over
a very short amount of time so you can't
really judge if this is successful or
not yet and it says like 50 percent
month-over-month growth but it's run
like 6 weeks but it's been 6 weeks and
and a hundred percent of those companies
were other hundred of the customers or
other companies in the YC batch right so
it's like you know it's hard to really
get a sense of these things but I
thought this pretty interesting idea
what are you thinking up about this ok
so if I was this guy I would bet my life
that this could be a company that makes
a [__] ton of profit so there's the
nearest competitor the
I could think of his calendar calendly
calendly is a plugin for Gmail it's a 30
million a year company that's
bootstrapped out of Atlanta started by a
guy who moved here from I think Nigeria
cool story
andrew wilkinson a guy i respect and
like thinks that calendly are i think he
thinks it's total [__] and that
Google could totally clone it I disagree
with I disagree with that assessment I
think that Crone can for sure be a very
very profitable software company I'm not
convinced that it that they should raise
venture capital because I yeah I
wouldn't raise venture capital for them
I was them if they needed money and just
to start I would say raise a million
dollars and just make this make like
stoop big it's stupidly profitable right
yes the route they're going because
they're in YC but yeah I hear that I
think that's a valid path I don't think
they're gonna need a ton of capital
there's not a big they don't need a huge
engineering force they don't have to buy
a bunch of assets you know this is a
software play that really a motivated
team of six to ten people could support
if I was listening to this podcast I
would say and I was technical I would be
like oh that is a great idea there their
website if you go there right now kind
of shows how the product works and I
would just completely rip it off and
scale but be far more scrappy cuz I
don't think these companies out here are
scrappy and I think that someone could
build it and be able to pay themselves
five million dollars a year and netting
though yeah you know that so I think
this is a good idea I also like this
general Zhang er of company so our
friend sue Lee tipped me off to this a
while ago he goes I just think super
human 4x is a good investment thesis
right now
and so he loves super human he loves the
business it's doing really well and you
know we were looking at this company
called linear which is a it's like a bug
tracking software so every big software
company tracks there bugs usually using
JIRA or some like old-school ticketing
system nobody loves using JIRA it's just
like you know you it's a must you have
to be organized around your bugs and
linear just made like a slick looking
JIRA
and and so we you know we talked to them
thought about investing in them did you
end I didn't end up it was a bit of a
competitive round and then I could have
got in at the end but I sort of cooled
on it because when I tried to bring it
into our company there was a lot of
security concerns not that they were
doing something wrong but you just have
to do a lot of work to be enterprise
security compliant and pass those checks
and they hadn't done that work yet now
in reality they're gonna do that work
it's gonna be fine and they're gonna get
there
it's just it got out of sight out of
mind for me because I stopped using them
I forgot about the are you know and
you're making investments right now no
now I'm on startup investments I have
cooled off referred for the time being
is it freeze so okay so verdict on Crone
how do you say it Krong Krong a verdict
for me is great company to own I think
it will work I don't know if it's good
to raise money on yeah agreed
thanks a good idea good product I think
there's other products like this if you
just take a superhuman Forex and you
take any work tool that's massively used
and you just make extremely slick ui/ux
for for that this can work with to-do
lists this can work with email this to
work with calendar this can wall you
know how I would do that is I would log
into Gmail I'm gonna log into Gmail
right now I would log into Gmail I would
click that little the drop-down arrow
the drop-down or no the Google Apps
thing on the top right right I would
look at search gmail calendar Docs drive
sheets slides sites groups contacts hang
out and that would just oh wow there's
way more YouTube Maps news translate
photos admin my business out and you
just put that on a bull's eye or a
dartboard just close your eyes and just
let it is that's what you do air table
did this for Excel notion did this for
Docs superhuman did it for email there's
a new one that's doing it for
presentations yeah so let's talk about
that I don't know much about it it's
called pitch I oh right
or pitch Co I think it's pitch Tonko is
it awesome or something I don't know
like why are people talking about it so
much pitch calm do they get to calm
that's like that's how you know it's
legit nothing $100,000 domain name
what uh what why are people talking
about that so much so I saw this the
first time so this is again you know
just like air table did for Excel these
guys are trying to do for PowerPoint so
PowerPoint also has hundreds of millions
of users it's a critical business
function and Microsoft does not make the
UI UX better over time they do not do
smart things in the cloud and so you
have on the low end you have Google Docs
and Google sheets Google slides and on
the high end you have right now
Microsoft you know PowerPoint and these
guys are trying to to do a better job
making making a sexy PowerPoint and I'm
down with sexy PowerPoint I always love
their website it looks great pitch calm
and it looks like it's ready to come out
now I've seen this thing this has been
like for over a year I believe maybe two
years that I've seen this this website
like this based off the people who are
recommending it on their on their
homepage I feel like I know the people
behind this yeah it's like you're
friends with all the testimonials yeah
great I'm very yeah I like that I don't
know anything about it other than what
I'm seeing on this website and yeah and
so this is one where I think great
market to go after your execution
obviously has to be good but like you
know but but that's okay
it's better than going after a bad
market because then even great execution
doesn't do jack [__] for you I have
another one that's like this on the
excel side that's called causal so I've
been talking these guys I'm not quite
enough I don't think I'm like an
official advisor but I just get might
give these guys a lot of opinions so
causal is it basically tries to give
everyone the ability to do like data
modeling like an excel wizard or like a
and so they have some cool things you
should just if you just google causals
rent versus buy calculator you can see
what the end output looks like they make
this I calculator of rent verse by how
do you spell that CA you si el that's
causal causal app calm is their thing
and then if you just Google causal app
rent verse by you can see it it's a cool
tool I don't think they've quite got it
to work I'm telling him they're trying
to make it to they're basically too
smart
so they're trying to do like data
modeling and data science like oh look
how easy it is to make a linear
regression or Monte Carlo it's like yeah
but you don't do that frequently you
should just make it where it's really
pleasurable and easy to do simple
formulas and spit out awesome charts
like I love to do that because what air
table did was air table took the part of
excel that's just rows of information
and they made that sexy but what they
didn't do is calculation people use
Excel for calculation and charting and
an air table doesn't do that so if you
did the calculation and charting and you
made it beautiful and sexy
you could win and these guys aren't
doing that and pitch calm I changed my
opinion they're gonna fail I went to
their about page and they have nine
employees and they're all founders oh
yeah that's a that's a bit of a red flag
literally you know their about page they
have nine people it says co-founder for
all every employee yeah that ain't gonna
work these are also like amazing head
shots that they took for themselves yeah
so co-founder and a QA engineer
[Laughter]
it says co-founder next to all yeah
they all do pretty legit investors okay
so I say Andrea is an investor in them
yeah okay I'm excited to see what they
got well I want to see it that's been
two years okay so let's go to the next
company the next one is art in res art
in res so the idea here is you can buy
fine art in installments and you know I
personally didn't know too much about
the fine art market I think my hunch is
that you know a little bit more I think
you like to look into these things so
tell me what you think about this idea
and what you know about the fine art
market yeah so masterclass is one of our
partners we work with masterclass I went
and met with the founder his name Scott
in New York a couple weeks ago a couple
months ago
and I learned a lot so mmm fine art is
one of the largest asset classes in the
world but master class is not about art
right or what do you mean sorry
master works as well math master works
is a website where you can purchase
pieces of a Basquiat or a Pablo Picasso
in the same way that you buy stock in
publicly in the publicly marked traded
markets so
but art fine art is a massive massive
asset class but it's incredibly illiquid
as in you you either have to have 30
million to buy a Basquiat or you don't
get any upside so what master works is
doing is allowing people to purchase it
with a minimum I think of a thousand
dollars and what I learned meeting with
those guys was how how great that that
that that as an asset class how great it
could be so for example David Geffen
from Geffen Records a big entrepreneur
during the financial crisis he was
famous for saying that his fine art went
up 30% while his normal equities went
down significantly let me see what else
I have a bunch of stats here so I think
I think I think it's really interesting
if I wanted to look at how this company
could do I would look at Etsy so as Etsy
has traded at a 50 to 80 price earnings
ratio which is really really good
I would a right now is in the gutter but
I'm really I think that marketplaces can
be quite large and I think that I
personally was shocked at how large fine
like fancy art is and I thought it was
like I thought that there was only like
a couple paintings sold a year that made
a difference and in reality it's not
it's not that way so what's your
takeaway are you okay okay so let me
explain a little more about art rest
from what we know so here's what here's
what they say the value proposition is
that you can buy fine art in installment
so you were saying masterworks lets you
buy a piece of a piece of art they sort
of fractionalized it these guys say it's
yours but you can hear on a monthly
payment plan this has been a big trend
in e-commerce anybody who's been paying
attention to a firm or after pay these
are multi-billion dollar companies that
are just saying even low-priced items
right here's a $40 item but you can buy
it in four easy installments a firm is
doing quite well both of those companies
are gonna go public or it's looking like
they will right after perceptual already
public and firm is I think going to go
public and so there and there's there's
more sizzle there's there's others that
are doing this too so that's a very good
business to be
and I believe and so so that's what
these guys are doing they said they've
sold 36,000 dollars worth of art in
three weeks this is unlike a firm and
unlike after paid they're not a payment
option on other market other websites
they are their own marketplace and so
what they're trying to do is they give
artists the ability to sell their work
they say most artists don't even sell
their work so they say list it here we
offer people the ability to buy in
installments so more people can buy so
we've more buyers in our pool and they
they get the artists to put their link
to their store just like an Etsy store
in their bio so they put their art in
res link at the bio and that's driving a
lot of users because these are you know
Instagram artists are artists with an
Instagram who have you know a hundred
thousand followers and they're getting
them to buy of all these different
artists and that's going to drive
traffic that's a lot how SoundCloud grew
early on was going for these independent
artists and then saying cool we'll give
you an easy way to host your artwork in
that case music but you know here at
share your SoundCloud profile and that's
how they got tons of traffic and built
up their marketplace and so I think
that's what these guys are trying to do
I think this is smart the art market is
one of those markets that's bigger than
you think because you don't even you
don't even learn about it till you're
already rich and what's already rich you
don't do start a company in it and so I
think it's one of those big invisible
markets to most entrepreneurs who are
scrappy and don't own you know like a
pencil let alone a piece for I so I
would have agreed with you and before
you start talking I agreed that it was
great but then you the way you described
it if okay so I would I would be against
it if if Etsy is competent they can
destroy these guys yeah I think it's
gonna be hard to because ed sees niche
is handmade crafts and I think that's
just fundamentally different than fine
art I think when you it's like putting a
bottle of wine next to a Budweiser right
in the aisle it's it's a little bit I
don't think the people who want their
art to be sold or fine art to be sold or
want to buy want to be next to somebody
who's making bracelets that would be my
that'd be my bare case against that okay
I buy that I buy that but oh okay I get
it so I see a painting on here it's
$3,000 I could pay overtime
for 24 months for a hundred and thirty
seven dollars okay so my question is
this is this pay overtime feature even
that unique enough to build most your
company on top of why not just like have
a normal art store and just uninstall a
firm yeah that's a good question I don't
know why they're not just using one of
the existing installment plans you know
why are they why are they owning that
piece of it it's like an art marketplace
but then also this financing program
when they could just use one of the
existing financing programs so I'm
looking at it now yeah I I'm changing my
mind it's stupid okay we'll see jury's
out on on art and res I'm not an expert
in this area but I'm unsure of something
there my bet would be I think
marketplaces are really really freaking
hard to start and and so I for that
reason I think that it's gonna be
incredibly difficult and they definitely
a vanilla they've done that yet but you
know so I would say odds are always
against any marketplace being successful
but I do like the fundamentals of what
they're trying to do I don't think this
is a stupid I don't think this is a
stupid bet to take if you're an
entrepreneur but I do think still
likelihood is that it doesn't work like
most startups I think that it okay but
there's a difference here of working and
just building the wealth and then
working by raising money no I mean the
business working now not the reason
money lots of companies can raise money
yeah but what I mean is should I think
this [__] for sure can make a good
living for the owners the question is is
if they raise money then will work or
will it not my prediction is if they
raise money it's gonna fail I feel like
that's your prediction with most things
I think you just don't like what people
raise money for the most part no the
next one that we're gonna talk about
carrot I think that could work let's
talk about it okay so carrot it's they
provide loans and a line of credit for
influencers and that's interesting and
the reason it's interesting is I use I
have a million dollar line of credit
with a company that provides line of
credit for for media companies this
clearly works in some cases
influencers can it work maybe but the so
the company that I use it was started by
a DreamWorks exec it has over 100
employees and they have billions of
dollars and in and and I don't know what
how do you describe billions of dollars
in credit yeah they have billions of
billion to over a billion dollars to
deploy I think it's great cuz I'm
totally hooked on their company and I
don't plan on leaving and I think I pay
them like a thousand dollars a month for
this what do you what do you use it for
your company expenses or person yeah
company yeah so we don't really use it
but when a rainy day comes and we need
money I have that set up right and so
and so the other example here is clear
bank where they're basically providing
credit to e-commerce companies and
they're saying great you don't don't go
raise money for this if you can show
that your credit worthy by looking at
your Shopify data then will we will
front you the money you need for
inventory or for Facebook ads or
whatever else you shouldn't go over as
venture capital to pay for Facebook ads
and so the interesting thing here is the
big ideas
the real big ideas that come out of Y
Combinator don't always sound like big
ideas to start Airbnb is a great example
of that yeah you know when it was when
it was on ycs list like this it would
have been called air bed-and-breakfast
it would have been like you know rent
out an air mattress in my apartment and
it would have seemed like a small idea
and this is one of those two words it's
like two influencers really need credit
do they really need loans what do
influencers need you know this for and
it just turns out I think that there's a
lot of influencers and this might be a
hidden big market it might be something
that influencers really actually do need
this capital they are not there the
traditional banks and lending
institutions don't know how to how to
assess an influencer for
creditworthiness in the same way that
they didn't do it for e-commerce and the
cool question I have is how does the
influence or use that capital to invest
and grow their business like for
e-commerce I get it for your business I
get it you're gonna invest the money
you're gonna grow your business what
does an influencer really do to grow
their businesses it adds is it to pay
for stunts that's good contact like what
are they doing with this money that's a
good question and I don't think anything
but let me go let me go a different
angle here when you bought your house
which
was your wife listed as in an earner yes
was she listed as self-employed yes well
what I mean listed by like like for
example when you got your mortgage sorry
when you got your mortgage to see did
she say she was a sole proprietor did
you say that you're a 25% owner of a
business do I say that now okay when she
was getting approved for the mortgage
was it hard for her
no she well it was a lot of paperwork
but it was it wasn't hard like she had
the income to show it but it just
required like mine was simple w2 submit
they are like yeah got it we understand
your economics for her she had like you
know this rollercoaster history and a
whole bunch of different entities and
like all those different stuff that like
was very very hard for them in fact we I
just refinanced because the interest
rates have dropped like crazy and we
didn't even use her this time cuz the
lady at the bank was like if we can
let's just do this off your income like
I don't want to do all that paperwork
again for your wife that's what I think
the opportunity is when I try to buy a
home because I'm an entrepreneur I told
them I own I think the threshold 20%
they go they said you own more than 25%
of a business I said yes and they go ok
we need to see the last X amount of the
years in P&L and I showed it to him and
it was profitable or whatever and they
still gave me a hard time I think that
if I was this company carrot I would I
think that there's a big opportunity who
can provide home loan for home loans for
small business owners I think that's the
real opportunity here yeah and maybe the
introduce of a so here's some of the
stats about them right they've loaned
out a million dollars in the last six
months the average payback period is 45
days extremely fast payback that the APR
is very high because of that so even on
a low APR because of the fast payback in
annualize is that 40% and now they're
rolling out a credit card after they do
credit card I'm sure that they would
want to get into other financial
services and if they can be sort of the
financial services for influencers or
the bank for influencers that's very
interesting because this will always be
a niche market that is overlooked and
misunderstood by the traditional banking
system and so that's the bull case the
barricade
I don't know I don't know what the
influencers need this money for I don't
know if they can actually pay it back
and I don't have how creditworthy they
actually really are so the the strategy
here is you get into a market you get a
ton of you buy ton of share you people
like you and trust you and you're
profiting and then you start launching
more and more stuff to them which I
personally love which is a trex model in
this case right what yeah and it's what
I do
I mean it's what I did for a living
we're built we build up a free email
list that we sell more stuff and the
more and the more the more I mean yeah a
lot of people do it and but you gotta
get them locked in early and you got to
give a enough people so I think that
that's cool and that actually brings us
to a good point of our other next one
how do how do you pronounce this and
I'll tell you why there's a there's an
angle here well what's this one called
how do you pronounce that we're just
gonna call it Lila I don't know what it
is it's Lee Allah I don't know amazing
yeah they need to change their name
because that's hard to pronounce right
so it's it's stupidly simple it's it's a
it's a product that helps women freeze
their eggs pretty straightforward but
what I think could be cool with these
folks as well as Kara is once you get
this customer on the hook
there's loads of products that you could
sell them in the same way him started
with viagra and now is doing hair loss
and then now they're thinking about
doing testosterone and doing X I've been
doing Y whatever I think you could do
the same thing for both carat really
well and this egg freezing one hello
little Lilia yeah how you say so bad
name great idea great business you know
this is one of those you just close your
eyes and invest this is how I would
treat it yeah
so the so here's some stats that I I
went and found this is not from their
deck I just wasn't found this okay and
this number was shocking do you know
that only according to CNBC only like
11,000 people freeze their eggs a year
is that right it's not a lot yeah not a
lot but it's growing at 25 percent a
year and I actually buy that I think
it's going to grow significantly Gen Z I
think they're gonna put it off more and
more I also think that so large
companies like Facebook and Google
actually subsidize
and pay for it so to get your eggs
frozen it costs between five and 20
grand a year if you're in San Francisco
it could be 18 grand if you're in a
smaller city it could be 6 grand so it's
really expensive
it's very invasive it takes four to six
weeks where you got to give shots in
your arm and it's like huge needles it's
a it's a it's just a it's intense [__]
but you know it's about having children
so it's a pretty big deal and you're
willing to put up with all that it's a
pretty big deal my question is will they
be able to convey be able to so first of
all there's not that huge of a market
right now ten twelve thousand people
what would this new company be able to
convince a young woman to use them as
opposed to her doctor right and the
other other existing services that
surely exist around this right like I
don't know the competitive landscape but
I do like where all the trends are going
so I think that you know the data shows
that people are having kids later
they're getting married later and that
this is becoming less fringe and less
taboo over time and so that's what's
going in the favor of this is that more
people the market for egg freezing is
growing and it's becoming more
serviceable now do they had what I don't
see here is some unique go to market
strategy
oh here's how they're here's how they're
going to acquire our customers
differently than how anybody else would
I also don't see they're really talking
about their expertise and how they you
know why that why they're gonna be able
to build trust in a way that's better or
different than anybody else so that's
what I think's missing from this limited
information we have here so you know how
you and I talk about distribution and
product right and how oftentimes product
isn't an issue sorry
we talk about product and distribution
and how a lot of people particularly
first-time people think well if the
product is good it's gonna sell itself
in reality that's not the truth because
there's way more great there's a ton of
great products that die because they
have no distribution and there's a ton
of [__] products that crush because the
distribution is amazing and so in this
case in the same way that hims is just
reselling other people's [__] right like
hims isn't interesting it's just generic
viagra their products nothing good
it's just that they like smacked cute
branding on it and they made it so man
can call the call and get it and young
men don't have to be embarrassed about
going to the doctor I need to see
something like that from this company I
think too in order for for it to work
because what the service they're
offering doesn't seem particularly
different right right yeah exactly they
haven't made it less invasive less
painful less cost
they haven't innovated on the product
side that means they need to innovate it
on the marketing side of the go to
market side so that's what I don't like
about this but I love the space that
they're in and I think there's gonna be
a winner I don't know if it's this
company or another but that's what's
great about this one yeah and do they
have you I don't know okay here is I got
some information on them okay so it
looks like what they're doing is they're
not actually doing the work they're just
a middleman for the clinic so in reality
they're almost like lead gen yep so they
have a $500 concierge service that they
offer first so how do we educate you
handled you through the process and
basically qualify the lead yeah so what
they're doing is they are not they are
not actually providing the service
they're just a marketing company for the
service providers if that's the case I
like this I think it's cool yeah I have
a friend who does a company called yo
derm and what they do is the same thing
around dermatology so it's telemedicine
but in reality what they're doing is
they said most people who need to see a
dermatologist are going because of acne
most people who have acne get the same
prescription that prescription is you
know something that they can just get
quickly from a doctor the biggest
bottleneck is getting an appointment
takes you know 27 days on average to get
an appointment with the dermatologist so
what they did was they built a marketing
company that basically says hey do you
need to see a dermatologist this is a
faster easier way to do it just do it
from like FaceTime your doctor and then
they have a bunch of doctors who just
write these same prescriptions all the
time for the same acne medicine because
that's what people need eighty percent
of time and twenty percent of time they
say you need to go see a doctor it's not
acne it's not just the generic thing and
and then they're white labeling the
actual acne medicine and they're the
ones delivering it and that's the how
big is that they're doing well
I love that okay so we talked about cron
art art and res karat and Lil Lilia
that's just right name you have $100,000
to put in one which one you're gonna do
mmm alright let's take a look
it's not gonna be cron for me
I'm also gonna say it's not gonna be
Lilia because even though I like the
market for all those reasons we
mentioned I don't know why this is the
winning company I don't see them doing
anything special and this is the what we
have to tell people is once you meet the
person behind it that could totally
change your decision crucial is right
this is not based on the people at all
because you could meet someone and
you're like they're so formidable that's
like you don't care what you sell them
in right I think if I was gonna do this
if I was this is crazy to me that I'm
even saying this but I think I would be
putting it in Arden rez I think I would
put it in because I think if they can
get the marketplace spun up it's gonna
be valuable and I think that this is an
overlooked marketplace so overlooked
market so I like that it's a marketplace
as a model not lead-gen not not anything
else and then they on the other side I
think if they can get I have a feeling
that the sort of fine art marketplace
has not been affected by technology in
the same way as all the other industries
have and so I'm curious to see what they
can do so I'll bet the hundred K on the
art and res and I would write it off as
a loss because that would assume it's
going to be a loss all right I would do
a cron okay why cron I just think it's
it's super easy for them to be in
default survival it's so easy like I
think that they can get like a hundred
thousand dollars in monthly revenue like
really fast I think their churn might be
high but III think that it's just
because of the market size and because
it's an impulse buy and if this just
saves you a little bit of time I just
think that they can get to 10 or 30
million dollars in recurring revenue
inside three or four years with very
little capital and so their default
alive pretty easily and depending on how
creative that entrepreneurs are they
could expand beyond that so I'm gonna go
with cron okay I like that also who
would buy them though well like for
example Microsoft BOTS sunrise calendar
I believe it was a Honda that people
really liked was a pro professional
calendar and they got bought for how
much but I know like inbox Cal bought
for 100 million for making a slicker
inbox
you know by Google and then sort of
thrown away
sunrise got bought so so I think that
there's potential for an acquisition
there by one of the you know big
companies that cares about you know
enterprise and productivity and whatnot
so there's there's a chance there I just
want to be evil and just cloned half of
these things on this list
yeah that's not evil that's that's it's
not evil that's just capitalism but I I
do it like I some of these ideas I think
are really stellar I don't know how it's
I tell you the one that I would invest
in it's not even one we discussed and
then we got to go I'll do it in 30
seconds company called duffel they're
doing fast deliveries on college
campuses and it's a horrible idea but go
ahead not horrible not horrible tell you
why what they do is they buy the popular
stuff that kids want like Ben and
Jerry's and chips and whatnot beer they
put it in an apartment and then they
deliver it to you on scooter when you
order it so average cart is $16 they
make $5 per delivery and they're
delivering in a very lightweight way on
the same in a very tight geographic
boundary so they don't have a bunch of
logistical issues there's a company
called puff or go puff have you heard of
those guys no what's that it's this but
it's basically it's this and they're
doing over 100 million dollars a year
right now and they're just two kids out
of I don't know Penn State or something
like that I don't know where they are
but somewhere in middle America and so
I've seen this model work I think that
this is a hot business idea you have
puffer it's good thing two websites go
puff calm you're saying they do a
hundred million in sales
yeah more than that I believe and so
they're in you can see all the different
campuses how profitable are they I mean
I don't know all that right I don't have
all their financials but I mean 100
million like their net profit they pay
the dry I mean or is it like where the
driver gets most of money and most so
they're they're at 163 million a year is
the thing and I don't think they even
raised that much money like let me look
at their fundraising for forego puffs I
don't think they raise too much oh no
they have now raised a lot
how much eight hundred and sixty six
million dollars
oh you described as two kids well it was
Softbank invested in them and
recently and is a huge round that's a
soft bank backed up the truck and them
but anyways I think this market works
and I actually think it's great that's
off bank backed up the truck and put the
touch of death on this company if I'm
duffel I I believe in what I'm doing
there's a lot of college campuses out
there to make this work can I give you
two that I would do right now okay
this is just purely off of reading about
their market and like a description of
the company the first one is build plain
comm project automation for commercial
construction I think that with the
recession this can make this company a
ton of money their previous companies
were acquired so they're solid but just
I love
software that is in boring industries
like commercial construction that can
help people just save a little bit of
money it's called right bill build plane
like III that will take off and be big I
like that it's not sexy and then the
second one is true north fleet did you
see that one I didn't see this now we
give independent truckers the resource
the resources of large fleets and so
basically what they do is you know a lot
of truckers are just small business
owners right there just like uber
drivers but they just do truckers my dad
is in that industry so that's how I know
about a lot about it and they're pretty
raw they just you like up until recently
they didn't use Twitter or anything like
that they would just have their CB
radios and their cellphone and my dad
would call them and be like hey I got a
load for you to go pick up in
Bakersfield and then I need you to drop
it off at the Walmart in this place like
that's just how it would work and this
company is is building bits like
software for small small trucking
businesses and I don't I think people
vastly underestimate how trucking is
like the backbone of America and how big
logistics is in our country so I'm very
bullish on that one I like it okay cool
yeah if you like this let us know we're
gonna do either more of these YC sort of
company deep dives
since this batch list just came out
there's like a hundred companies we
could go through if we wanted to and if
you don't let us know be like that was
boring don't do it again and
yeah we can go through a few more next
week Sean did you have you had topics
already that you wanted to go over we
can do these next week huh
yeah we'll do it next week Oh Thursday
Thursday okay
well thanks for listening this one was a
little ghetto because we're all at home
hopefully the quality was sufficient
enough yeah i for one enjoy the ghetto
pond I hate it
[Music]
you